wer bei schon gründen sind jeden tag
er weiß schon heute morgen sind wir
morgen wieder ist neu beginnt
liebe leute wir fahren im sessellift
schneckentempo
da hoch wir sind hier im oberbayerischen
alpenvorland sie gesagt ich schon fast
in den alpen
also wir sind heute mitten in den bergen
bei einer alm
essen bauzeit
mit dem boot zeitmesser ich liebe
bootsmesse trinken milch aus der kuh
natürlich gibt es hier auch käse und
einmal schmalz so kann man es auf das
panorama nacht schon was anderes als aus
dem supermarkt hier noch einen kleinen
gürtel
das tolle daran ist dass viele sachen
zum beispiel butter und käse hier selber
an der einem auch gemacht werden damit
das funktioniert schauen wir zusammen
jetzt müssen wir die kühe holen zu
merken coni
kommst aufstehen
fahrbahn kommen
hier sind sind die zwei frachtstücke und
jetzt schauen wir uns mal an die mir die
merken kann ich versuche es auch mal mit
den händen
ein ganz eigenes gefühl sofort sinken
das geht schneller
für mich als stadtkind ist es natürlich
ein erlebnis
frisch gemolkene
möglichkeiten gefiltert und jetzt immer
die neigung die zentrifuge und machen
sind den rahm abschöpfen sehen die
butter punkte
sehr schön die interessante welchen das
hier ist der rahmen
keiner war
wir durften jetzt ein bissel über die
schulter gucken
das ist ja schon ein haufen arbeiten ja
die kinder schon selber gehen der
modische karl das ist nicht immer so
einfach wie man sich das vorstellt dann
haben wir die milch filtert wobei leider
keinen tropfen zu schützen sollte sie
wirken sharing das gold von da ein
gehalt das
wahrscheinlich sechs meist erstmals halt
wenn jetzt wichtig so du warst du davor
gas wasserinstallateur an bist
aussteiger wie hat sich dein leben hier
so verändert sehr positiv die zeit
später rolle mehr ich dann nach der
sonne aus
das ist halt nature so hört sich das
back to the roots danke dass wir kommen
durften